certains de noël on se sait pour les
effets mais l'insee ne repartira pas
avec l'histoire fantastique qu'elle
convoite rupture de stock
il faut dire que les fêtes de fin
d'année sont l'occasion d'offrir des
livres dans les rayons de cette
librairie
on cherche la perle qui fera plaisir
mais ces points vraiment alors c'est un
livre que vous allez choisir en fonction
de vos orientations ou en fonction de
ses goûts faut donc en fonction de ses
goûts pas de mes goûts mais en fonction
de ses goûts alors il va falloir que je
sois quoi pas policier par science
fiction donc on va rester sur plus des
choses de la vie des histoires de belles
histoires
c'est plutôt en fonction des centres
d'intérêt de la personne et de
ses loisirs livres pour les fêtes de fin
d'année vous vous y pensez naturellement
naturellement entre le bon roman le
livre de cuisine ou la référence
historique
le choix est immense comment choisir un
livre à offrir chacun sa méthode
exemple le petit pays de galles fayat et
ses cinq prix dont le goncourt des
lycéens sorti en 2007 encore du succès
une vraie source d'émerveillement
j'en ai acheté au point et je lui ai
offert à ce que je sais qu'ils aiment
lire qui aiment s'élever vers l'écriture
et les belles lettres
en tout cas le livre pour vous ça reste
un beau cadeau c'est pour moi le cadeau
numéro et parmi les best of de cette fin
d'année le livre référence des 200 roms
produits dans le monde
une famille française de la
martiniquaise audrey sélestat le
concours 2018 mais pas seulement à la
troisième place vous retrouver le libre
d'imany et dalila daniel zaïre et theo
fennell effectivement ce n'est pas un
roman qui est nouveau mais c'est un
moment toujours considéré comme baisser
les ans un best-of chine ou qui
continuent à très bien souvent les qu'on
aime ou relativement guénouvry en
période de fêtes
en tant que 2 vous avez le livre du
professeur et méchant nicolas son
esclavage et à la première place des
ventes à travers le monde mais aussi en
martinique devenir le tout dernier de
michelle obama pour ces fêtes de fin
d'année cette seule librairie en a vendu
500 offrir un livre est donc toujours
très tendance